- Battle Rap.
A war of words using intricate schemes,
raw syncopated delivery,
and witty wordplay.
Lyricists turned the art of rap
into a clash of the titans.
- Now I'm gonna have the crowd
swinging from these bars.
I ain't with the monkey business.
I like that move. Pocket check back,
(crowd cheers)
but it's just too bad
he ain't got no money in it.
(crowd shouts)
- Over the years, Battle Rap has expanded
from the hip-hop underground
and into mainstream pop culture.
Whether it's Eminem's "Eight Mile,"
Netflix's "Rhythm and Flow,"
James Corden's "Dropped the Mic"
or the epic rap battles
of history on YouTube.
Today, Battle Rap is a professional sport
with superstar athletes and
leagues all around the world.
- And one of the most popular leagues
is the Ultimate Rap League
or URL for short.
- We all together basically
organized the culture
and just made a business out of it,
really making it and turning this whole
art form into a league.
- For over a decade,
the URL has drawn over 650
million views on YouTube
and provided viral Battle Rap moments.
- Consider it an art form, because
the fact that
these guys go up there and put on a show,
it's all theater, it's
all performing in art.
- So where did Battle Rap come from
and how did it become so
popular across the world?
- [Arthur Buckner] This is the story
of how Battle Rap evolved
from underground competitions
to the global streaming
phenomenon it is today.
(intense hip-hop instrumental music)
- I've been a Battle
Rap fan for a long time.
For years I've followed
the culture on YouTube
watching my favorite battlers
how I watch my favorite
drummers or basketball players.
But I've always wondered how
Battle Rap got its start.
So let's get into it.
- The art of spoken word has been around
since ancient times.
For centuries, Grios from West Africa
have recounted tribal history
to their communities
through music and poetry.
In the West Indies, Calypso artists
have engaged in Picong Duels,
where singers fire rhyming
insults at each other in song.
- [Picong Duelist] I will
tell you plain and candidly,
don't stop look back and smile
because you have a face like crocodile.
- In black American culture,
young people played The Dozens.
A verbal game where people take turns,
lobbing humorous insults at each other
in front of an audience.
But Battle Rap as we know it today,
didn't start until the 1980s.
(upbeat hip-hop instrumental)
In the early eighties,
hip-hop collectives attended conventions
to compete against each other
for prize money and bragging rights.
At first,
these competitions were friendly face offs
to prove which crew could do a better job
at rocking the crowd.
That was until the
Christmas Rappers Contest
at the Harlem World Club in 1981.
That's when a battle
between Kool Moe Dee and Busy Bee Starski,
changed how MCs approached
rap competition forever.
Busy Bee's claim that he would knock
out all bums before the contest,
was not taken well by Kool Moe Dee.
Determined to make a point,
Kool Moe Dee entered the contest
after Busy Bee finished his set
and rocked the crowd with a verse
that directly attacked Busy
Bee's credibility as a rapper.
♪ Hold on Busy Bee, I
don't mean to be bold, ♪
♪ but put that "Ba-Ditty-Ba"
bullshit on hold. ♪
♪ We gonna get right
down to the nitty-grit. ♪
♪ Gonna tell you a little
something why you ain't shit. ♪
- Kool Moe Dee's rhyming disses
inspired other MCs to adopt his style
and engage in small rap battles
at basketball courts and
corner stores around New York.
This style helped move the the genre away
from the old school, upbeat,
party themed hip-hop,
into a grittier art that
showcased lyrical ability.
Roxanne Shante was
among the first female
Battle Rappers in the 80's,
and a Rap Beef pioneer
starting the Roxanne War,
with her infamous disc track,
"Roxanne's Revenge," in 1984.
♪ My name is Roxanne and I came to say, ♪
♪ I'm rockin to the beat
and I do it every day. ♪
- As hip-hop entered the 90's,
the tradition of calling
out your peers on record
continued, influencing
several infamous Rap Beefs.
Memorable conflicts between artists like
Ice Cube and Common,
Dr. Dre and Uncle Luke,
Tupac and Biggie,
and most notably, the exchange
between Jay-Z and Nas,
have been etched into hip-hop history.
♪ Went from, Nasty Nas to Esco's Trash ♪
♪ had a spark when you started,
but now you just garbage. ♪
♪ Talk about me, laugh behind
my back, but in my face ♪
y'all some "Well Wishing,"
friendly, acting,
envy, hiding snakes and snakes"
- Over the next decade,
battling on the streets for fun
grew more popular and became a subculture
of competing rappers testing their skills.
(mid-tempo hip-hop music)
In the mid nineties, hip-hop festivals
like Scribble Jam, featured
freestyle battle competitions,
that would draw up-and-coming
rappers to battle
for a chance to earn prize money, trophies
and exposure.
Seeing the appeal of
freestyle competitions,
TV networks began
incorporating Rap Battles
into their programming.
Shows like HBO's "Blaze Battle,"
MTV's "MC Battle"
and BET's "106 and Park"
would bring Battle Rap
to worldwide television.
In the early two thousands,
Troy Mitchell, better known
as Smack White, had begun
interviewing and filming
several established artists like 50 Cent,
Beanie Siegel,
DMX
and Cameron.
But he wasn't just covering celebrities.
Smack would also film with
up-and-coming East coast rappers.
He would record their freestyles
and produce any music videos
to help promote their image and mix-tapes.
Smack then took all of this footage
and created a DVD Video
magazine called "Smack DVD".
- I used to go around,
do exclusive interviews,
shoot videos, help them
promote they projects,
help them, show them in
environments and places
that you won't normally see
them in, on a regular standard,
TV network, like MTV, BET.
- [Speaker] Right?
- [Smack White] Yeah.
You gonna see them in the studio,
you gonna see 'em in airplanes,
in they house, on they
block in they neighborhoods.
- Vlogging, before vlogging was a thing.
That's literally what it was.
- Heavily bootlegged, smack DVDs
made it to outlets all around the world.
And became one of the most popular sources
for uncensored hip-hop news and music.
Smack began including rap battles
near the end of each volume.
And, in keeping with Battle Rap's origins,
these battles took place
in gyms, barbershops
and on street corners where
crowds could watch the show.
- I closed it off with a
classic hip-hop battle.
And,
that segment of the DVD got so popular,
people used to buy the DVD
with mainstream artists like,
Eminem, 50 Cent,
Cameron, Fat Joe,
Buster Rhymes.
I had all these major artists
on the front of the DVD
with major coverage of these artists.
And people used to
basically go buy the DVD
and go to the back of the DVD first,
to watch the Battles.
- Smack. I literally, my first
experience is exactly what
you described here. I'm interested like
"What's all this stuff?
What's this? No, no, no, no.
Me skipping, skipping, skipping,
this one we gotta see,"
so I never even caught
the promo, the interviews.
But the battle was the...absolutely.
(Smack chuckles)
- Waiting for his chance and
now he feeling time's perfect.
He probably ain't want a battle
just wanted to meet me in person.
- Then World Star came into play.
- I ain't think about World Star.
- And they made a killing
because they wasn't
into content creation,
but they was into traffic.
- Absolutely. Absolutely.
- So they killed me.
That business model,
at that time was a success.
Moving forward to 2000 and 2009,
I just had to figure out,
what was the most valuable
content that still exists
with what I was producing?
And that was Battle Rap.
- As Smack DVD rap battles
grew in popularity,
Smack saw an opportunity
to create a platform
for Battle Rappers to perform
in front of larger crowds.
That's when the Ultimate
Rap League was born.
Better known as the URL,
The Ultimate Rap League
moved from the streets
and began renting venues
for Battle Rap events to house
their growing number of fans.
By 2009, the URL started
posting their battles
on YouTube for viewers to watch online.
It was Tay Rock's Seatbelt
Haymaker that shook
the internet, that solidified the URL
as one of the most exciting
channels to watch on YouTube.
- You get another cut and another cut.
It looked like the seatbelt won't work
(crowd roars)
and I'm trying to buckle up.
- And there are more
and more Battle Rappers
becoming superstars in the community.
Like Geechi Gotti.
With 57 battles on YouTube alone
and over 32 million views,
Geechi Gotti has been
URL's champion of the year
for three years in a row.
As Battle Rap culture grew online,
more and more leagues started
popping up all over the world.
Leagues like the Canadian
owned "King Of The Dot,"
the woman lead, "Queen of the Ring
and the Filipino "Flip Top"
and the UK "Don't Flop,"
have pulled in millions of subscribers.
Do you consider Battle Rap to be a sport?
- Yes, absolutely.
When I first started representing
the art form of Battle Rap,
I modeled it after,
I tried to model it after the
UFC, you know what I'm saying?
Everly influence from the UFC...
- Y'all don't play, yo hold up. Hold up.
- Just wanted to come up with a name
that people will always remember.
- So now that you know how
Battle Rap got started,
let's break down how it works.
A battle is usually two competitors
going back and forth for three rounds.
And at the end, it's up to the audience
to decide the winner.
- We saw Mike (indistinct)
- [DJ] Yeah.
- There are several widely
used forms of wordplay
but the most common are
Angles, Schemes, Haymakers
and Punches.
Punches are short for punchlines.
That the line's delivered
at the climax of a setup.
- You gang bang what?
I'm supposed to be scared of 'em?
I will have you and your flag hanging
off a balcony like I'm
proud to be an American.
(crowd cheers)
- Extra powerful punches
are called Haymakers.
They're usually accompanied
by a small pause
to generate a stronger crowd reaction.
- I was up in the hotel,
loading rounds for cousin,
big rounds I'm stuffin,
they say, "ill in the lobby,"
I grabbed the nose running.
I'm coming down with somethin.
- Oh my God.
- For flair and creativity,
A battler may also use a Scheme.
This is when a rapper
presents a subject matter
and then follows it up
with a long form parallel
comparing the subject
matter to something else.
- Your career is just like Shaq's.
He spent four years in Orlando
and learnt the harder
way he couldn't hack it.
Smack brought in a certain PG
and then we all believed in magic.
You became lost and jealous
ain't find out the way to compete.
- While a lot of Battle
Rap verses are written,
there are also freestyles and rebuttals.
Freestyles are where you
improvise bars on the spot.
You can reference your opponent's clothes
or anything that's
happening in the moment.
A rebuttal is similar
but instead, you improvise bars responding
to something your opponent just said.
And lastly, we have Angles.
An Angle is a personal attack
that points out your opponent's flaws.
Angles are all about focusing
on specific things about your
opponent to break them down.
- I ain't saying your shit wack,
but bro, it's the same move
every time you kick that.
Set up, punchline, set up, punchline.
That's how you spit that?
Just a candy wrapper with four bars
you a...
see how easy it is to predict that?
(crowd roars)
- Best punchlines come from
with what resonates to people.
So you don't wanna say something that
a bunch of people don't know about
and then it's like when
you got a audience there,
they can't pull out their
phone or go to Google
and look it up.
So it's just about,
reading the room, knowing your audience.
On the URL stage I'm gonna
get a little more intricate
because they already understand exactly
what it is that we do.
- What are the differences between
a Battle Rapper and a Studio Rapper?
Or what, what are some
common misconceptions?
- Common misconception is
Battle Rappers can't make music.
They, put us in this very, very small box.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a bad stigma they got on us.
They say we can make music.
I just don't understand
because Battle Rappers
are clearly the best writers,
as far as element of being an MC.
'Cause you only get one opportunity.
You can never say this again.
You have one take.
You have to wow a audience,
time and time again with new materials.
- In my whole career,
everything I did was a throwaway
'cause I can never use...
If I use those bars again, I'm wrong.
- You recycle it.
- I'm wrong for using my own lyrics again.
So our job is much harder.
- Even if they're not
creating chart toppers,
Battle Rappers still have a huge influence
on popular culture today.
Whether it's ESPN commercials,
the BET Hip-Hop Awards
or reality tv.
Then there's shows like Nick Cannon's
"Wild 'N Out"
which has taken inspiration
from Battle Rap culture
and even features URL stars Conceited,
Charlie Clips
and Hitman Holla.
What kind of things do you
see coming in the future
for Battle Rap?
- I'm trying to make
this a household sport.
What we have accomplished so far,
is amazing because,
if you pay attention to what's
going on in this culture,
you see so many different
territories have adopted,
the style of this art form.
- It's an art, right?
- It's an art.
- It's entertainment.
And these guys has found a way
to provide for they families
to entertain us this way.
And they put on a show for us.
And that's what it's about.
- Even though it started
in the underground,
the sport has become so
popular that teenagers who once
dreamed of being the next big rap artist,
are now dreaming of being the
next great Battle Rap star.
- Before you go, I
wanna let you know about
"Fight the Power How
Hip-Hop changed the World,"
a new PBS series hosted
by hip-hop legend Chuck D.
It's about how hip-hop
became a global movement
that spoke truth to power.
Check out the link in
the description below
and let them know Sound Field sent you.